Stephen Hawkings was talking about the
the possibility of alien life
discovering us and that it would be a
terrible terrible thing if it did happen
if you look at what has happened to
other primitive life-forms when we
discovered them primitive cultures and
we've discovered them do you share that
same opinion that if something did find
us I don't have a strong opinion on that
question but I have an analysis of his
comment okay he is worried about the
possibility of aliens enslaving us Oh
based on the reality that we've done
that to ourselves yes just think about
that his fear of aliens derives not from
actual knowledge of aliens but from an
actual knowledge of ourselves
anytime a more advanced civilization has
come upon a less if a technologically
advanced civil for the less advanced
civilization and that happened in North
America South America North America with
with Europeans South America
the Spanish Australia with with the
Brits never boded well for the less
technologically advanced civilization
his factual knowledge of that leads him
to suspect that aliens would be exactly
the same and I I'm not that skeptical I
don't think all life forms in the
universe have the basal primal violent
attitudes that we do as a species I've
not been given reason to think so
but don't you believe that things
advanced because of competition and
competition forces things to be fairly
ruthless it has been argued that if you
colonize if you're a civilization that
colonizes the galaxy that it's a
self-limiting exercise why because here
you go you ready we start here on earth
is you and me boy all right and you take
that planet I take this planet
and now we have both have offspring that
are just like us and we want more
planets all right we reach a point where
expansion is not possible because we are
warring with ourselves to gain the
territory that each other has obtained
so it has been argued sociologically
that the very act of wanting to colonize
is self limiting against successful
colonization of the galaxy because to
colonize the galaxy it has to be done in
an organized way all right
you take this sector I take this sector
but if I want territory and I want it
now and my kids want it now I want that
territory not this other one in fact I
want it all that kind of attitude breeds
violence it breeds war in the intra
galactic war so it may be that the very
kind of civilization that could
peacefully colonize a galaxy is not the
kind of civilization that would colonize
the galaxy at all that's heavy very
heavy what about the idea that any
advanced that's my first comment another
one he's got he made another comment
about we should be a multi-planet
species checked ourselves against an
asteroid rendering one stinked it makes
a good headline and it sounds like it
makes sense but I'm not I'm not there
with it yeah of course I want backup of
course let's be a multi-planet species
fine but but I would do it for different
reasons I'd do because it's cool not
because I want to protect human human
species from extinction no that wouldn't
be the reason to do it can I tell you
why please list every reason why you
think we go extinct when we trash earth
another when we can't live off of it
anymore
an asteroid is coming there's some nano
BOTS gone astray
okay pandemic and virus a pandemic okay
so it seems to me that if we want to be
a multi-planet species Mars would be the
one because it's a 24-hour day
it's got seasons we would have the
terraform at first but then we all move
their duty ship a billion people
here's Mike where's my point whatever it
takes to terraform Mars and ship a
billion people there it's got to be
easier to deflect the asteroid whatever
it takes
to terraform Mars to turn it into earth
if you had the power of geoengineering
to do that then you have the power
geoengineering to turn earth back into
earth but there are occasionally a
things that we miss right because of the
way that so so you so you say okay
whatever it takes to Geoengineer Mars
and ship a billion people there it's got
to be easier to create a perfect viral
serum that makes us immune to all
possible disease it's got to be easier
whatever that takes but isn't it
possible that there's some asteroids
that we just will not see until it's too
late then you put up whatever that takes
I mean whatever but there's ship a
billion people there a billion tit B we
have said what do you put ten people
there what you wanted not sell it your
species right okay and if an asteroid is
coming that you can't deflect which
would surprise me if you could ship a
billion people to Mars you just let them
all die what what is that what's your
you plan to you let all the earth people
die in the Mars people survive just so
you can save this B don't save everybody
I'm not buying into the premise this
cable-car ology premise that you have to
save one to not save the other and yeah
you know you know cable-car ology if I
see the cable car you know someone's in
the tracks you let them go you let him
go if you steer it out of the way but
then you actively kill two people
instead of passively killing one person
from what do you do I'm not buying into
that premise for this question I'm
simply saying that whatever it takes
it's got to be easier to put up some
kind of net that finds any asteroid that
could possibly harm us and zaps them out
of the sky
there's gotta be easy is the last
question is is it possible that the
reason why we are never visited by
extraterrestrials is because the way
one is it because the weigh stations
they have visited they visited during
comic-con the costumes weren't as good
as ours okay three three three they've
observed us and judged there's no sign
of intelligent life on earth okay but is
there another possibility that
civilizations don't ever get to travel
like that because what happens is as
they advance and as their technology
advances they become instead of a
biological entity seeking to spread its
genetics throughout the universe they
become some sort of symbiotic artificial
life that as they create as they advance
their technology and as they continue to
innovate they reach a limitation in
biology and that eventually create
artificial life that sees no desire
whatsoever to travel Oh interesting so I
would say that's a great philosophical
question I would say that the day we
create AI if the AI is everything we are
except more and not emotional
then I fully have an urge to explore
maybe otherwise is that it's not us but
wouldn't it cool those doors like in
Monsters Inc and start going dimension
to dimension instead of with jet yeah
they figure out the fourth dimension
yeah wouldn't that be the best way to do
things and then they figure it out and
then they would figure out a way to
travel better than any way we could but
if the fact that we want to travel and
we're creating versions of ourselves
called a I wouldn't want to travel but
why would it be curious if biological it
then it's not well if we create every
neurosynaptic
map right of our brain into silicon into
a computer and recreate our
consciousness as humans the human brain
but wouldn't that human version of AI
would there be like an infinite version
of a either hey I could create itself it
could why would
limit itself to all of our emotions and
sexual desires and jealousy and all the
ridiculous things that are holding us
back they could sure sure no I'm not as
fearsome of AI as others are I you know
we're not gonna make an AI lookin human
being because the human form is not the
best or ideal form for anything did you
see ex machina yes good moment you
didn't love it no it was good I loved it
okay well that's the first thing you
bought for sure for sure right yeah for
sure but I'm just saying it's one of my
favorite movies I want to marry the
movie it's just awesome movie so then
marriage would no longer be about sex or
just be about reproduction because just
go to your room with your sexy bar I'm
hoping that that's one of the first
things that people figure out they
shouldn't do anymore once they get smart
enough to symbiotically attach
themselves to artificial intelligence I
was watching what was it Family Feud one
of the questions was if you're we asked
100 married women if you could have a
second husband for only one purpose what
would it be something like 70% of it
said just for sex whoa damn a husband
for only one purpose just just for
getting stuffed just so that's a [ __ ]
wake-up call for a lot of men Don that
[Music]